if i have a representation of me as
distinct from you
and if that
entails an increase in the degrees of
freedom namely adding in this extra kind
of hypothesis and everything that it
entails then
i'm going to have a greater complexity
but it's a complexity that is more than
paid for by the uh by the increase
increase in the accuracy
and i you know
just coming back to your my original
point um
yeah i think a lot of the work um that
you've done at the cellular level
um would be very gracefully translated
to the societal level and to things like
economics and to
eco niche construction um in
um and i know uh chris is probably uh
wanting to say this
but language has one way of facilitating
that notion their ability to
um to efficiently with minimum
complexity in this instance um do this
distributed cognition so i'm both
trained being trained and learning at
the same time and we're doing it
together to invent some kind of
generalized synchrony
so i mentioned language for chris there
but the font hope he wants to pick that
one up
oh
well well again what i'd actually like
to do is back up a little bit
and uh put some of what you just said
into very simple active inference
language
if if i see something happening
on my
markov blanket on my interface with the
world
then i always have the question
uh did i do that or did the world do
that
where the world means everything outside
me
and
in a sense
the answer is always the world did it
so the question becomes
did the world do that in response to
something i did to it
or did it just do
it not not in consequence of any of my
actions
and someone gets immediately to this
kind of babbling scenario that we've
talked about many times
in which
an infant or a robot or some system
is trying to figure out
by
measuring correlations
whether
the world's inputs to it have
anything to do with its inputs to the
world
and
just
asking that question
requires enormous
representative capacity
because one has to represent one's
actions
and represent them pretty well in time
and one has to
have a good memory
to represent enough actions to get any
kind of statistical support for drawing
an inference about correlation
and
that memory has to
be represented as a memory
uh not just part of one's current input
so i think this
question that you
posed
is really the key question
faced by any agent at all
that's trying to get a model off the
ground
which
which in a sense gets back to the
question that mike asked early early on
about how does this all start
uh
maybe it starts with babbling
in very simple systems
you know i i was thinking recently uh
that this this whole issue of how many
agents are there and where is the border
between the agent and the world and how
do you self-model that border is is a
fascinating topic and there's a there's
an amazing um uh developmental model for
this which is which is that you know we
often talk about one embryo and the
embryo does this in the embryo does that
but actually what happens at the
beginning let's say for example an
amniot embryos is that there's a there's
a flat blasted disc which has just a few
cell layers thick so it's kind of think
of it like like a frisbee and it just
has a few sub layers
and normally what has to happen is that
one point in this in this disc breaks
symmetry and then organizes the primary
axis of the first embryo and basically
tells all the other cells
don't do it because because i'm doing it
and that's how you end up with one
embryo now that process is very easily
perturbed and and i many people have
done it i used to do it in my in my
graduate work and what you can do is if
you perturb that process that initial
blasto disc that undifferentiated sort
of pool of of cells which are these sort
of proto
uh low level proto uh proto agents that
pool can break up into not one embryo
but actually multiple and so you can
have so i did this in in bird embryos
and you could have twins and chicken and
duck and things like this you can have
in humans humans have exactly the same
structure um you can get them head to
head you can have to get them side by
side you can get all sorts of geometries
you can get triplets you can get
multiple individuals awry emerging by
different partitions of this of this um
really kind of
medium this particular medium where
where you have a bunch of cells and you
don't know ahead of time how many
individuals at the level of how many
larger individuals so embryos are going
to arise from this medium because the
the the dynamics by which in this you
know local activation and long-range
inhibition and things like that the the
dynamics that break up that that
undifferentiated ocean of of potential
selves into one two or three or more
selves is actually it's very dynamic it
can it can go different ways
and then you get interesting interesting
things like this so for example you
might know that human conjoined twins
that are you know sort of stuck together
side to side one of the twins often has
left right asymmetry defects and it's
because when you have two twins side by
side the cells in the middle both twins
can't quite agree on who they belong to
are they the right side of this twin or
are they the left side of that twin and
both twins think they belong to them but
in fact they're overlapping the same
cells and so one side will have correct
left and right the other guy the other
side will have like two rights for
example right and this ends up this ends
up giving one of the twins laterality
defects with respect to hardened gut
patterning and so so their models each
twins as as the collective of cells
tries to compute uh things like which
which
where things are and what's left and
what's right and so on their models can
disagree with each other they can they
can draw the boundary between self and
world in different ways and you can have
these sort of disputes over certain
areas as to where who they actually
belong to
and and so so i'm just i'm just
incredibly interested in this in this
process of of emerging of
individualization so to speak out of
this like ocean of of potentiality these
cells you know 50 000 cells and some
number of individuals at the um at the
embryo level will be formed and each of
them will have specific goals amorphous
space each of them will try to achieve
very specific morphologies uh and uh and
they've and then you don't know ahead of
time how many there were going to be you
know